des l'événement de la semaine et ils se
trouvent sur netflix alors que les
plateformes regorge d'inventivité et de
moyens pour tenter de créer et lancer la
prochaine série qui va cartonner
cette semaine c'est un français qui crée
l'événement à travers le monde il s'agit
d'omar sy est encore peur que m'a offert
sa splendeur avec la série du pain dans
laquelle il interprète le rôle titre le
comédien français a réussi l'exploit de
se retrouver en tête des séries les plus
regardées cette semaine son explique ce
aux états unis mais pas seulement dans
dix autres pays cités en france aussi la
série a un fort retentissement et fait
l'objet d'une large couverture
médiatique et réseaux sociaux parle du
phénomène et la sauce semble avoir pris
en quelques heures seulement
exactement ce qui prouve si netflix ne
communique pas sur les chiffres de
visionnage de ces programmes on sait que
lupin ce club dans les programmes les
plus regardés du moment tout contenu
mélanger maintenant tu connais une série
qui raconte l'histoire d'un homme fan
d'arsène lupin qui tout comme lui des
titres de jeux au gentleman cambrioleur
pour venger son père en commettant
quelques vols au passage vendredi
prochain et une fondation qui va mettre
aux enchères à collier alcoolique et
appartenu à marie antoinette et qui vaut
des millions sauf que la vente va pas se
passer comme prévu
parce que se connaît on va le volet une
chose est sûre lupin semble avoir réussi
à voler à tous ses concurrents la place
de numéro un alors lui pas avec omar sy
comprenez vous le succès de la série
française
alors il y en a qu'un qui dit non alors
kevin vatant qu'est ce qui vous arrive
alors je pense que cette série a
bénéficié surtout d'un marketing à
l'américaine grandiose faut quand même
rappeler que c'est une série a perdu 2,2
millions d'euros l'épisode qui est
énorme et ressent le top 10 dans plus de
90 pays jeu mais oui c'est un business
avant tout essayer le marketing est
énorme s'étaient ingérées à l'américaine
omar sy qui est on va dire que la
locomotive de cette fiction
je la regardais et comme beaucoup de mes
amis au china je me dis oui ça c'est ce
regard des clichés sur nos amis a pas
grand chose de crédible dans cette
fiction je ne me remets ça choquant
c'est génial
j'écris énorme tout ce qu'on veut ça je
le marais mois mais en tant que série il
n'y a rien de crédible à dents on ne se
on ici on s'identifie à la norme et
genton ce livre mais il souffre il ya un
phénomène qui est bien connu sur netflix
et que le bouche à oreille c'est vrai
les gens les uns s'arrêtent dans le même
temps découvrir mais c'est parce que
t'es sympa tu en es tu si j'étais un
port aucune encore j'ai du mal avec les
seuils français je penses tu de ta plus
belle la vie monge ville et ses dangers
mais oui non mais moi je vis ça marche
c'est franchement j'ai l'impression de
ne pas avoir eu la même série que toi
c'est très bien produite voulait tous
les acteurs sont pas des ectoplasmes ils
ont bien des caractères bien défini on
s'attache à chacun de deux mois c'est
très bien fait c'est pour moi ça sans
faute c'est très bonne série il ya
surtout au marché aux états unis est
venu un jour plus coupat et du marketing
serait qu'ils ont fait un coup de promo
assez fort dans le métro ah oui oui
lupin il a une particularité qui se
déguise maquis comme ça échange
d'identité et la sqaf et omar sy est
allé lui-même
regardez c'est dans la série lupin mon
personnage
hasan est un professionnel de la
diversion il est capable de se faire
passer pour n'importe qui on importe
pour arriver à ses fins
aujourd'hui on va vous prouver qu'au
delà de la fiction même dans la vraie
vie
parfois on voit
on ne regarde pas
[Musique]
premier jour
vous pouvez m'aider
ça va coller merci beaucoup monsieur
très gentil
[Musique]
je vous l'avais dit
vous m'avez vu
exceptionnel réalisation oxmo puccino
fabrice allouche que c'est vraiment la
série de ceux de ce début d'année 2021
et je suis bien sûr content pour lui
parce que c'est vrai que en amérique il
n'avait pas encore vraiment transformer
l'essai ces rôles étaient pas forcément
important pas trop important et là je
pense qu'avec ce service hier et va
décoller vers des portes et où je crois
qu'il faut c'est que franchement ohmacht
on va dire que ça il ya dix ans il est
intouchable qui est sorti donc ça fait
un record historique
là en 2021 dix ans après un record en
record en record historique en france et
je sais pas moi omar il a un charisme il
est il et il est en fait nous tous les
bois il est beau il est beau il est beau
il est même à travers le monde se forme
en passant par tous les plus gros en
fait le met à l'échelle lemieux plus ou
en fait et moi même le premier j'étais
enfin moi pour moi je pensais qu'il
allait incarner arsène lupin s'inspire
de la parcelle nombre passerait si un
jour ça que c'est chez netflix derrière
oui spontanément le développe fortement